[Musik]
rund 60 Kilometer neue Tunnelröhren in
und um Stuttgart gebohrt gegraben oder
gesprengt
[Musik]
ein neuer unterirdischer Bahnhof samt
Zulaufstrecken entsteht Stuttgart 21
Deutschlands größte Baustelle
Meisterwerk oder Milliardengrab bis zu
6000 Menschen gleichzeitig schuften an
den Mega Projekt das am Ende wohl
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro kosten
wird
[Musik]
zweieinhalb bis drei Meter fressen die
Mineure sich hier jeden Tag voran durch
das Gestein unterhalb des Stuttgarter
Flughafens Hubert Rams ist der Polier
für diesen Tunnelabschnitt trägt also
die Verantwortung gibt den Ton an
in vielen anderen Tunnelröhren für das
Mega Projekt Stuttgart 21 ist der
Vortrieb schon abgeschlossen hier sind
sie noch mittendrin die Röhre treiben
sie mit diesem Bagger voran im
sogenannten klassischen bergmännischen
Vortrieb sprengen würde hier nicht gehen
weil die Wasserwerte das nicht hergeben
weil die Nitratwerte so hoch sind dass
man eigentlich wenn man springt dass man
dann noch mal drüber kommen mit
Tunnelbohrmaschinen die anderswo bei
Stuttgart 21 eingesetzt wurden schaffen
Sie bis zu 20 Meter am Tag doch auch die
können Sie hier nicht nutzen die Kurven
sind zu eng beim Tunnelbau müssen
mehrere Arbeitsschritte direkt
hintereinander passieren damit nichts
einstürzt wenn der Ausbruch fertig ist
wird noch vermessen ob das Profil okay
ist weil das Profil alles okay ist
bewährungssauber machen Anschluss
Bewährung die Gittermatten drauf und den
Spritzen Spritzbeton mit dem sogenannten
spritzmobil die Arbeit unter Tage hart
dunkel staubig 12 Stunden Schichten auf
9 bis 10 Tage am Stück
Hubert ist Österreicher wie viele
Mineure er hat schon Tunnel überall auf
der Welt gebaut Algerien Chile Indien
hier leitete ein Team aus bulgarischen
tunnelbauern relativ einfach irgendwann
lernst du eigentlich aber hier auch
bulgarisch lernen ist nicht ganz zwei
Wochen aber es geht mit Händen und Füßen
und wir von der Arbeit was versteht der
braucht mir nur was bedeuten und sagen
dann funktioniert das kurze Kaffeepause
für Hubert im Baucontainer die nutzt er
zur Besprechung mit seiner Bauleiterin
sarah ist 33 Jahre alt und eine der
wenigen Frauen die auf der Stuttgart 21
Baustelle arbeiten im Tunnelbau sei man
wie eine große Familie erzählt sie also
wir verbringen mehr Zeit miteinander als
eigentlich zu Hause mit unseren Familien
und das merkt man dann auch also man
feiert dann zusammen Geburtstag oder
trinkt abends mal zusammen wir grillen
zusammen
und man trifft sich immer wieder also
wenn man die Baustellen wechselt und
dann fünf Jahre später da darf man sich
wieder bei den Weg und freut sich dann
auch diejenigen wiederzusehen
etwa 10 km vom Flughafen tun dann
entfernt mitten in der Stuttgarter
Innenstadt auch hier müssen sie sich
ranhalten damit der neue Stuttgarter
Hauptbahnhof nicht noch später fertig
wird
von oben wandern die Gleise des
bisherigen sackbahnhofs unter die Erde
in diese Halle
isernatik ist einer von dutzenden
bauüberwachern auf Deutschlands größter
Baustelle sein Einsatzort die letzte der
28 kelchstützen die in Zukunft das Dach
des unterirdischen Bahnhofs tragen
[Musik]
rund 22.000 Eisenstäbe verflechten die
Arbeiter prokelstütze jeder Stab ist
unterschiedlich gebogen esan muss darauf
achten dass alles an der richtigen
Position sitzt muss jeden kleinsten
Fehler dokumentieren wir reden
eigentlich wirklich von einem Kunstwerk
in jeder Stütze wie ungefähr drei bis
400 Tonne Eisen verlegt und so ungefähr
zwischen 650 bis 700 Kubikmeter Beton
auch mit eingegossen
Wahnsinn wirklich einzigartig und
Wahnsinn die Kelch stützen sollen das
Wahrzeichen von Stuttgart 21 werden
weltweit noch nie zuvor gebaut bei ihrem
Entwurf war völlig unklar ob sie
überhaupt realisiert werden können
architektenträume wie kompliziert und
kostspielig sie werden war damals
offenbar egal
auf der kelchstütze spricht es an die
Eisenflechter auf Mängel an
wir haben jetzt da ein Problem
Betondeckung unterschreiten können wir
zusammen anschauen freundlich im Ton
hart in der Sache ich versuche genau zu
sein aber auch auf der anderen Seite
vernünftig zu bleiben aber wenn das
nicht kommt dann wird das problematisch
sein aber wenn es noch eine andere kommt
dann ist es in Ordnung das eisenflechten
eine mühsame Kunst für die es keine
Maschinen gibt alle Arbeiter hier kommen
aus der Türkei dort sind die weltbesten
Eisenflechter zu Hause in vielen Dörfern
wird das Handwerk vom Vater auf dem Sohn
übertragen
na ja generell ist die Arbeit auf dem
Bau schwer aber der Beruf des
eisenflechters ist definitiv der
härteste
Kia ist so kompliziert dass sie ohne 3D
Modell direkt vor Ort nicht arbeiten
könnten einzigartig
das ist für mich komplett neu ich habe
sowas noch auf keiner Baustelle gehabt
oder gesehen
arbeite ein Deckenfeld der zukünftigen
Bahnhofshalle von unten pumpen Sie den
Beton nach oben
[Musik]
mit sogenannten flaschenrüttlern
verdichten die Männer die Masse dann
müssen sie alles glatt ziehen
40 Millionen Liter Beton fließen
insgesamt in Dach und Säulen der
Bahnhofshalle weiß Beton mit geheimer
Rezeptur so bislang nirgendwo anders
eingesetzt hier ist er schon trocken wir
sind jetzt dabei die vorhandene
Betondeckung festzustellen das heißt wie
viel Millimeter beträgt der Abstand
zwischen Betonoberfläche und der erste
bewerbungsstab was hier betoniert wurde
soll für mindestens 100 Jahre halten
wir haben eine
einzelne in der Mitte passt und
ansonsten
sehen die Ergebnisse aus
und weiter am anderen Stellen der
Riesenbaustelle werden schon Schienen
verlegt baulogistiker Dennis Teile
liefert den Nachschub zu den gleisbauern
die warten tief im neuen tunnelnetz auf
die Lieferung
jetzt fahren wir den anderen Tunnel
drüber das ist die Vernetzung unterhalb
der Erde ist ja das was das Ganze
ausmacht ist echt clever gemacht und
weiter
115 Meter lang ist jede Schiene wiegt
fast 7 Tonnen insgesamt zieht die
spezialorg 900 Tonnen an Fracht
gefährlich wenn die wegschnitzt und in
die Beine komplett weg senden also da
haben sie zwei gebrochene Beine
die Gleisbauer müssen heute alle
schienen Abladen um im Zeitplan zu
bleiben aber es gibt ein Problem mit dem
sie nicht gerechnet haben
Morgen und das sind die die hier sind
die Hälfte der Lieferung fehlt und die
Schienen liegen auch noch falsch rum auf
dem Wagen das kostet Zeit und Geld der
Baggerfahrer zieht jede langschiene so
weit es geht herunter dann setzt sich
die Lok langsam in Bewegung
Dennis behält alles im Blick er und sein
Lokführer ein eingespieltes Team
ja ich muss das komplett muss ich nicht
auf den verlassen gehen
damit ich weiß ungefähr was da hinten
los ist sehr nix
wir
drei zwei eins
[Musik]
in der kommenden Nacht wird Dennis noch
mal ran müssen die fehlende Ladung
besorgen zurück beim Vortrieb des
Tunnels unter dem Stuttgarter Flughafen
bei Hubert Rams Anweisungen an sein Team
okay
24 Stunden täglich 7 Tage am Stück wird
hier gearbeitet unter der Erde ein Job
der trotz aller Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
nicht ohne Risiko
es ist schon gefährlich aber es wird
immer sicherer
normalerweise weil einfach die
Vorschriften das nicht mehr hergeben wie
vor 30 Jahren
160 Meter haben Hubert und sein Team
noch vor sich dann ist der Durchbruch
geschafft dann kann der Innenausbau des
Tunnels beginnen der auf der anderen
Seite der Röhre bereits in vollem Gang
ist er startet mit Abdichtung und der
Betonage der Innenschale dazu brauchen
sie Spezialmaschinen individuell
angefertigt für jeden Tunnel und sie
brauchen Zeit viel Zeit
wir haben hier Blöcke mit bis zu 28,5
Metern Länge bis zu 800 Kubikmeter Beton
werden da eingebaut das sind Blöcke für
die wir alleine für die Bauzeit brauchen
wir ungefähr drei Monate und solch einen
Block herstellen ungefähr vier bis fünf
Wochen für die Bewährung weitere vier
Wochen fürs einschalten dann Betonieren
und
ausschalten
Nachbehandlung und dann sind wir bei
ungefähr drei Monaten pro Block das
Leben und Arbeiten auf einer Baustelle
ständig weg von zu Hause sein viele
wollen das nicht mehr ausgebildet wurde
in den letzten Jahren auch zu wenig sagt
elfried ILO
in Deutschland wo sag mal Bautätigkeit
sehr niedrig gewesen wird hat halt dazu
geführt es wurde weniger ausgebildet und
dieses Personal das fehlt heute und das
wird dann natürlich auch irgendwann mal
Führungspersonal das heißt also ich bin
jetzt mittlerweile mit der 50 und noch
zehn Jahre und der Nachwuchs ist
eigentlich da muss man ganz klar sagen
an der letzten Cash Stütze muss es sein
weiter aufs Tempo drücken verzögert sich
ihre Fertigstellung Gerät der Zeitplan
für die gesamte Bahnhofshalle ins landen
die Eisenflechter sind fast fertig
andere Arbeiter bereiten die Betonage
vor
nächste Schalung heute
ja ja kommt heute die polnischen
Betonbauer wollen loslegen mit
Holzelementen umhüllen sie die Stäbe
verschalen die Konstruktion eine Art
Tetris Spiel mit tonnenschweren teilen
Form für die geschwungenen kelchstützen
diese besondere Form muss auch von den
beiden Seiten das heißt von unten und
von oben eigentlich geschaltet werden
oder zugeschaltet werden damit der Beton
einfach rein fließen kann im Werbevideo
der Bahn sieht der neue Stuttgarter
Hauptbahnhof so aus acht Gleise umrahm
von den geschwungenen Säulen Stuttgart
21 nach wie vor ist das Projekt
umstritten auch weil es so viel Geld
kostet
[Musik]
1995 war noch von 2,5 Milliarden Euro
die Rede 2009 von maximal 4,5
2018 waren es dann 8,2 Milliarden
inzwischen liegt der Kostenrahmen bei
9,8 Milliarden Euro zum Vergleich der
Berliner pannenflughafen hat weniger
sieben Milliarden gekostet
Projekt Gegner hatten eine solche Kosten
Explosion für Stuttgart 21 vorausgesagt
sie kritisieren außerdem dass der
Brandschutz nicht ausreiche es zu wenige
Gleise geben
es wird durchgezogen auf Teufel komm
raus und das ist einfach das was einen
zur waistood bringt man muss das Ganze
gucken und das ganze wird eine
Katastrophe sein die Stuttgarter werden
auf viele Jahre nie mehr einen
funktionierenden Bahnhof haben die Bahn
sieht das anders und lässt weiterbauen
den aktuellen Zeitplan könne man
einhalten verspricht sie Fertigstellung
Ende 2025 6 Jahre später als bei
Baubeginn geplant an der letzten
kelchstütze fliegt das letzte
Schalungselement für diese Schicht ein
fast geschafft die Betonage kann
demnächst beginnen ein ganz besonderer
Augenblick für Isa
bedeutet für mich ein trauriges Moment
andererseits das ist so ein Gefühl dass
man sich äh auf sich selber stolz sein
kann und sagen kann dass ich auch bei
diesem Projekt mitgemacht habe das ist
eine riesengroße Ehre ESAM die
Betonbauer Mineure Gleisbauer und alle
anderen die am Mega-Projekt arbeiten sie
haben noch viel zu tun damit Stuttgart
21 sich nicht noch mehr verspätet damit
Deutschlands teuerster Bahnhof wirklich
in zweieinhalb Jahren an den Start gehen
kann
[Musik]